present our final award this man has
created some of the most iconic films of
all time
some of which screen this summer in
fortnite and on december 20th
i'll be sitting down for a conversation
with him on youtube to talk about the
home release of tenet
and his illustrious career and if you've
got questions for them which i'm sure
you do
send them our way using the hashtag
asknolen on twitter
but right now without further ado to
present game of the year it's my honor
to introduce
christopher nolan hey chris
thank you jeff it's an honor to be part
of the game awards
for me i've always been interested in
telling stories that
immerse the audience i like movies that
unfold in unexpected ways and pull
people into a world
when i look at video games i see a lot
of parallels with that kind of
storytelling
how a player's agency and choice
intersect with
more traditional storytelling methods
it's exciting to see and really quite
groundbreaking
tonight all six nominees for game of the
year are
true masterworks in immersive
storytelling to pay tribute to them
please welcome from abbey road studios
the london philharmonic orchestra
conducted by my old friend lorne balfie
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well that sounded fantastic and now the
game of the year award
goes to the last of us
part two
again uh big congrats to all the other
games we're nominated with
um everyone at naughty dog
i i can't wait to hug and high five and
get drunk with each one of you
uh that's gonna have to wait till next
year um
i want to just thank every person that
worked on this ambition game
within nine dog and outside shout out to
our
sony partners again scott rhodey connie
booth herman
hulst sean layton jim ryan your support
and trust in us
means the world and more than anything
and i know that i speak for the whole
team when i say this
we'd like to thank our friends and
family that stood by us and supported us
throughout
us making the scheme you inspire us not
only to make better
more meaningful games but to improve how
we make games
on behalf of everyone at naughty dog
thank you
congratulations to naughty dog game of
the year for the last of us part two and
congratulations to all our winners
and all the nominees around the world
thank you for joining us
virtually and next year hopefully we
will all be back together in person in
the meantime there'll be plenty of games
to play
congratulations also to pluto who is
voted by the fans as their favorite
emerging ballarant streamer
let's all go raid her stream right now
on twitch there's also the twitch gaming
post show that's coming up right now
at slash twitch gaming i'll be joining
them to chat about all the things you
liked and he didn't like
in tonight's show it's been a very
unique year but one thing that never
changes is our passion for gaming
and the games we love thanks to our game
awards team
and all the incredible developers and
publishers around the world
who made this show possible under very
trying circumstances i can't believe we
did it
take care stay safe happy holidays and
be well
i'm jeff keeley good night we'll see you
next year